so I have this yellow rectangle here and
I have begun to fill it with green
squares and my question to you and to me
is how many total green squares can I
fit into this yellow rectangle if we
don't make any of the green squares sit
on top of each other let's see I've
already we already have 1 2 3 4 green
squares and let's add a few more so I
could put one right over here so that's
one right over there and then I could
put another one right over here put
another one right over there and so I'm
gonna have 1 2 3 4 5 6 green squares can
be fit into this rectangle now let's
look at this big yellow square and we
have the same thing going on we've
already started to fill it with some
squares and my question to you is how
many total squares could we fill this in
with so let's start doing that so in
this space right over here and let's put
more of these these squares of the same
size these squares of the same size I'm
gonna draw them first and then we can
count them so there you go and then one
more right over here and so you could
fit well we're ready to count them 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 of these smaller squares
inside of this bigger yellow square